hey what's up guys my name is Jenna
welcome back to my OpenGL series so we
are back last time we talked about
creating this whole test framework and
test classes and all that and we had
something where we could actually create
test classes which extended like kind of
a base test class and we could kind of
demonstrate each individual OpenGL or
feature or whatever we wanted to really
do with OpenGL in kind of a sandbox test
environment that was really clear for us
to kind of I guess demonstrate and have
samples of the various pages that we
learned about in OpenGL and just various
kind of neural graphical tests that's
the kind of stuff that we're going to
use it for in the future
so if you haven't seen that video then
definitely check that out because today
we're gonna be extending that and last
time I gave you guys a bit of homework
to figure out how we could create some
kind of test menu where we could click
on a test and it would construct a new
test and then when we went back to the
main menu it would kind of delete that
test unload all the resources and then
kind of present us with that test menu
again and today I'm going to show you
one of the ways that we can actually
implement this so thank you to all those
people who shared their solutions
I think most them will shed on discord
so if you guys have enjoyed my discord
that is discord sorry it's the channel
of calm slash discord and then that's
kind of the invite link it's just a
great community of people where you can
talk about all kind of aspects of
programming develop and graphics games
whatever it is you want to talk about
all that stuff is there so that we join
that community if you haven't already
anyway let's just dive into some code
and check out a way for us to create
that test menu and have it kind of
construct and destruct class instances
for us okay so jumping into the
application does the agree file that we
have if you guys don't have access to
this yet by the way definitely go to
pager I'm a chrome for slash the Cherno
help support this series it really does
help me make more videos for you guys
and you'll also receive all of the code
kind of episode by episode as separate
commits on github so definitely check
that out and help support series this is
the code from the beginning of the test
framework episode and if we take a look
at what we have here essentially we
already have this test that we're kind
of presenting this test clear color but
what I'm actually going to do is start
off by just going to these tech this
test folder and adding a new
and it's gonna be actually you know what
wouldn't even have to create a new file
we're just going to do this in the test
on H header file and we will need a CBP
file because I do want to separate the
implementation so I will create a CPP
file called test dot CPP and over here
in the in Silvis namespace I'm gonna
create this test menu and this test menu
class is going to have it's just going
to be a test really so if we implement a
rather extend test class here and then
we'll have pretty much all of this stuff
so I'll just copy and paste that over
here umm I won't implement this and I'll
just mark it as override override and
override the cool thing about this by
the way is that because I didn't make
them cure virtual functions let's get
rid of this because I didn't make them
pure virtual functions we don't actually
have to have other ones we don't mean so
this is a great example I think someone
asked in the comments below why why I
didn't make these functions pure virtual
and I would do that by just writing
equals adora like this the reason I kind
of left them as just special functions
and implemented them with a blank body
like this is said that we could
selectively choose which ones we
actually wanted to implement ourselves
if there were equals zero if they were
all pure virtual I'd have to have all
three but with this method I don't
actually want on a potato or and just I
don't need to have them I can just go
ahead and delete them and then
everything will still work fine I don't
have to implement them it's just an
option that's given to me so this test
menu class is going to do two things
first of all it's going to contain a
collection of all of our tests and we
want a way to be able to basically I
guess present them with a specific name
so we need a pointer to a test class a
test instance I guess a test object
instance but I also want to store a name
that we can provide the test so that
that's kind of the label I guess that
appears for our button in the test menu
so what I'm gonna do is print a vector
of STD pair and we're gonna have a pair
of string and the actual test pointer
like this now here's where it gets a
little bit interesting I don't actually
want a test
pointa because that implies that the
instance already exists which would be
great if we kind of went with the
strategy of I just want to create all of
my tests at the beginning of my
obligation and then add them to my menu
and then like switching to them would
activate them maybe but I don't really
want to do that because what I'm doing
right is I've got my constructor and
destructor so what I actually want to
happen is when I press the button I
don't want to just activate a test
instance I actually wanted to create and
construct a test instance I literally
wanted to say new tests and when I kind
of go back out of that test I wanted to
delete the test so I can't just add a
test pointer because the test pointer of
course would be appointed to an already
existing object what I mean instead is a
way to construct that object and one way
that I could do that which I'm is what
I'm gonna do now here is I could
actually just provide it with a lambda I
could provide it with a function that
constructs that that test class of mine
so if we go back here I'm gonna make the
second element of the pair here an STD
function of just test point a here and
no parameters so this basically means
that this function returns a test
pointer and it doesn't take any
parameters so this is basically going to
return new tests depending on which test
we actually create and then that's gonna
be my vector now I'm going to call this
tests okay so I need one one angular
bracket here I'll include functional so
that I get access to the STD function
glass okay cool so there we go I've got
a I've got a vector of pairs and each
pair contains a string and a function
which returns a test pointer and takes
no parameters okay so I could have
printed a struct hit so creating an STD
pad but this is actually rather trivial
I don't really want to create called you
type in a new struct called like I don't
know test I don't know what I call it
somebody got tests so maybe like test
menu instance or something I'm not sure
there's no need to declare anything like
that we can keep it kind of anonymous
because we know it here that basically
this is just a collect a list write a
vector of strings and the actual test
classes which those those strings kind
of create because the string is just bad
because we want to give our button a
label this little makes sense when we
actually see it on the screen
okay cool and then one other thing I
actually want is a pointer to the
current test now the reason we need this
is because our menu is going going to
change the current test is active right
now application we don't have a current
test we've just got this what I'm
actually going to do here is have an
actual test pointer which is our current
text a cow is called current current
this is what we actually need to modify
it and we want the test menu to actually
do that for us now we could again pass
in some kind of lambda or something
which modifies this but an easier way is
going to be just depositing a reference
through that test pointer and then this
test menu is actually going to be able
to write to that pointer and thus change
the current test so in the constructor
here to pass in that I guess we'll call
a current test pointer and then if we
right click yeah actually let's go back
to that say cookie file so I can include
tests don't age and we put in namespace
the tests and then we can go back here
and implement everything we need by
creating the method implementations okay
cool I don't think when you disrupt it
actually because everything's stack
allocated anyway so we can get rid of
that destructor and then this is great
to merely do what I want that's because
it's the test namespace not tests so get
rid of that and do that okay so
constructor is gonna set current tests
to current test point up like that and
then online GUI render is going to
actually render that list that we have
so I'll just say for auto and this would
be I guess tests in our tests what we're
going to do is actually create a render
and I'm good button room now wise okay
what's wrong on here
Esther didn't know okay we need to
include a vector oops
okay so inside this tests when I'm going
to base the red or line blue button so
we'll say I'm going button label is
going to be that test this is a pad or
yeah so test first and
the a dot visual assist thank you dot C
string because it wants a C string one
second star pointer and then of course
if that button is pressed we basically
want to execute what that button says to
do and that button what that button says
to do is that actual function so we
really just need to call test dot second
like that because it's the function we
want to execute now we don't just need
to call it this returns remember this
returns a test pointer this returns the
new test pointer that is supposed to
construct for us so that's what we
actually want to set current test to so
current test gets set to that lambda
that constructs our actual test class
instance we haven't actually created
that lambda yet that function but we
will in a second let's include I am
going here because we need to okay cool
there we go so that looks pretty good to
me so we've got a we should have a list
of buttons and if we press the button
then it will hopefully
change that current test pointer to be
whatever this test actually returns as
it's kind of creation function okay cool
that looks pretty good to me let's go
ahead and create that test menu I'll go
ahead and include it over here as well
so actually to already be included
because it's in the test a shadow file
so we'll say test menu menu equals new
test test menu we're going to pass in
this current test I'll actually call
this current test just so that it's a
bit more split by default we'll set this
equal to null and then when it does get
created over here we'll set the current
test equal to menu because we wanted to
basically start off with the menu now at
this point you could add some kind of
command line argument or something like
that if you wanted this application to
boot up already with a specific test
this is very useful if you're actually
trying to test something because if
you're actually working on a test or
working on a new
technique or something or trying to
implement something whatever it is and
it's implemented as a test you don't
want to have the menu come up every time
and you have to click on it so every
time you debug your code many comes up
then you have to click on it menu comes
up that's a waste of time so you can
just get it to kind of open a test for
you kind of from the get-go without
having to go first to the menu and
instead of hard-coding that to just go
to a specific test or whatever you could
just have it as a command-line argument
that's really nice if you're working in
a team as well because it means that
instead of you accidentally checking in
the code that sets the test for specific
tests the one that you're working on you
can just have it as a command-line
argument which is technically still kind
of in your user settings and those
wouldn't actually be committed to the
project so yeah you could do something
like that if you like that could be on
those homework tasks or make it take in
the name of a testers command-line
argument and open that in maybe if
that's actually exact command line
argument and actually say ok cool so we
weren't worried about this test
psychologists yet now we are creating
everything on the heap here by the way
because we do want explicit deletion and
all that stuff so this test clear call
or whatever will kind of change in a
minute let's just make sure this works
first we have no way to actually add
tests and I'm aware of that we'll fix
that in a minute but I want to set this
up first basically what we're going to
do is when we start a new frame we're
gonna say if the current test is not
null right so if current test then we're
going to basically update the current
test and render the current test and
then we're going to begin our I'm GUI
window which is going to be just called
test I guess which is going to be we can
actually set the name of the test but
we'll keep it as just test for now on up
table taken zero I guess is at Delta
time and then this is actually what's
going to call I guess contest on Renda
oh sorry on I'm going rendered now we
are going to have to implement that back
button that I talked about let's go
ahead and do that now actually so if our
current test is not the menu test so it
doesn't equal
menu which record
menu or something like that text menu
just so that we're not too confused here
I like to call my variables meaningful
things even if it does mean making them
longer so we'll call this test menu so
the so if the current test is not test
menu and I'm going button I guess we'll
just draw a back our for now so
basically we're going to draw an iron
GUI button
I can't believe I drew that that was
we're going to draw an iron GUI button
which is our back arrow but that's
something gonna happen if the test is in
test menu right so I couldn't ask these
if statements but I've just added them
kind of side by side with and and
operator which means of course this
condition won't even be evaluated if
this is false so if it can if the
current test is not test menu then we'll
draw this button and if that button is
clicked and that's when we get into this
stage so what we want to do is delete
the current test and then set the
current test equal to test menu and that
is pretty much it
okay cool so now we have a way to get
back to our test menu really all we need
now as a way to actually create kind of
tests right so the way I want to do that
is I'm actually gonna add a function and
I'm actually gonna kind of write the
code it as its function exists already
a lot of people ask me what a good way
to write kind of modular complex code oh
just how to write code really when
you're kind of not sure if like you know
you don't want to just start running a
function because you're not really sure
what's the best for 10 what parameters
that you take the best way to do that is
just to pretend that the function
already exists and just actually start
by using the function so in this case
I'm going to pretend that that function
exists and into test menu I'm going to
just write test menu our register test
now I want to register the test I need a
pass and the types is going to be a
template so I want to register the test
clear color and then of course I want to
give it a name so I'll just use a
parameter for that and I'll call it I
don't know
clear color or something like that right
that's gonna be our play call a test
that is now what I want the function to
do okay I now nor the function needs to
be a template it needs to take in the
type it needs to
also take in the name of the test so
that it can display it in the test menu
right because we have our test menu
which displays those names as the button
label and then of course the actual
function needs to create a lambda that
creates a new instance of this class
type so it's really straightforward from
now basically because I've already
created the function I just need to
implement it now so it's gonna be
template type name t it's gonna be a
void function called register test going
to take in a Const string I guess we can
just take in a concert pointer we are
storing at string though so I guess we
could take in a char pointer because of
course we know that this actually this
I'm going rent as a child pointer but I
am converting it into a string which is
also fine because we might want to do
some manipulation or whatever and we
should be using strings anyway so I'll
still keep that here and then all this
is really going to do is add that test
into that list so just M tests don't
push back now we're gonna have to make a
pair here so make pair we're gonna pass
them that name and then we're going to
just create a very simple lambda doesn't
it capture any variables that's just
going to return nirrti
and that's it because t is the type of
class that we're actually creating okay
and then what's gonna happen is of
course as we call this register test
class with every kind of different test
type that would create the compiler is
gonna create a new version of this
register test function you know code
base that actually returns the new kind
of class instance that we requested
based on the type okay one thing I will
do is just quickly write for our sanity
registering test and then we'll kind of
print the name just because it would be
nice to know which tests we actually
kind of create I guess I'll not really
create but register because of course
we're deferring the creation until we
run this lambda and we're running that
lambda when we actually press that
button to create it because it gets
wrong right over here hopefully all this
is making sense play your videos for you
guys to watch about this definitely
watch the one on lambdas I'll have it
linked up there because and that of
course is going to explain how lambdas
work and how these kind of functions
that work career
getting called later how that whole
thing works also templates another good
video to watch so inside just check out
my secret feed series my c++ series if
you're not kind of sure what some of
these things are because I have I think
I've covered pretty much everything I'm
using this video in that series okay so
we are pretty much good to go we don't
need to create this anymore at all
because remember that actually gets
created when we press the button so
let's get rid of all this I think I've
implemented everything I'm not sure
because obviously I'm running the code
right here live so let's just hit f5 and
see what happens that's if I say that
very often well I just hit f5 and see
what happens actually get that on a
t-shirt okay cool so we have this test
we have clear color and then hopefully
if I press clear color look at that it
opens the clear color test shows us our
clear color we can change all of that
everything works pretty good I think
and then if I go back we go back to the
click on test now in this case you can
see it hasn't actually changed the big
collar which makes me think maybe it
hasn't work but I'm pretty sure it has
what I'm pretty sure has happened
because you can see it does go back is
that we're just not setting the click
color so if we go back here and do we
have a way to set the click color inside
the renderer I don't think we do
we'll just got clear right so maybe into
clear we could maybe add another
function called
set clear color and then this would take
in we have a math library we're never
math library I think right okay this is
gonna be too hot and I really want to do
this right now
so if we come back to application does
CBP we're just going to when we clear
the call out of waste going to the
college for black so she'll quit follow
a server 2000 from stairs over and 0 and
we'll set the Alpha to one just like
that okay so now hopefully we should say
that go back to black when we go out of
the test because that's how much you
work okay cool so if we click click
color we go there go back it takes us
back to play color now we'll be
fantastic we had an additional
to actually test this out and see if it
works properly but we're gonna kind of
get into that as we saw them coming
doing more tests the texturing tests and
all that I think next episode are
probably going to create a bunch of
tests and kind of divide out all the
kind of concepts that we've learned
right now in two separate tests so as we
continue on with the OpenGL series we
will be adding more and more tests but
you can simply come in to basis of the
framework is up and running you can just
add kind of multiple tests to this thing
and you'll have them all nice they've
cleared the menu and they should be
created upon creation upon like actually
looking a button and then destroy it
when we just right now there is a little
bit of a memory leak of course because
we don't delete the test menu or
anything like that so what we actually
need to do here is what I want to do is
I will eat the current test form
actually close the application now you
could argue that of course if we do
close the application of course the
operating system is going to clean up
anyway so we don't really need to do it
ourselves however to be nice if we
should still technically do it so what I
want to do is delete the current test
when we actually close the application
so of course when this while loop
terminates the while loop does the
jealous of the window just close while
loop and we start to chop this up shout
everything down and terminate it I'm
actually going to write delete current
test now here's the thing and the
process needs to be in this scope here's
the thing I also want to delete the test
menu however if the current test is the
test menu I'll be deleting things twice
so if current test does not equal test
menu then we're going to delete test
menu otherwise current tests already is
the test menu and that's been your
nation's leader so we shouldn't get any
crashes with this code let's just hit f5
and see what we can do here so if we
just close it right now we should be
fine because it just deletes the current
test which is the test menu and then if
we hit f5 again am I going to go into
that test and if we close it now it
should kind of delay but if the current
test and the test menu because the
contest is no longer test menu ok anyway
hope you guys enjoy this video
you did you can hit that like button you
can also show your support by your
educational conversation picture no
great way to get access to all the code
of course that I wrote today and all of
the other episodes as well huge shout
out as always to all of my lovely
supporters because these videos would
not be here without you guys so I really
am thankful for that and your support
means a lot to me I will see you guys
next time I'm gonna continue writing
these tests I'm gonna write one for
textures next time and then from then on
of course we can start learning more
about OpenGL and we'll have kind of a
separate test class demonstrating all
the stuff we learn kind of corrupt so it
so I'm really excited about that I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]